cinéma demain sur les écrans ghost dog
la voie du samouraï une histoire de
tueur à gages qui accomplissait tâche au
rythme du rap le réalisateur du film et
jim jarmusch et l'acteur qui interprète
le samouraï et forrest whitaker
déjà couronnée pour bird 2 au festival
de cannes il est dans la voie du
samouraï un black qui régissent sa vie
selon les préceptes zen avec quelques
adaptations quand même présentation
pascal deschamps et bruno l'hiver tout
cas ce que tu veux tu veux ma rolex
quoique et surtout ghost dog chien
fantôme et tueur à gages mais un tueur à
gages un peu particulier son livre de
chevet la règle des samouraïs sa
philosophie son code de l'honneur refont
un être à part un guerrier solitaire
soumis à une discipline d'un autre âge
surplombant la ville ghost dog est à la
croisée des cultures déchirée entre le
passé et l'avenir comme beaucoup de
jeunes de sa génération
on a dit aux jeunes noirs américains vos
racines compte pas la culture africaine
est inférieur primitive alors vers quoi
se soutiennent ils essaient de trouver
des succédanés rapid ici ou là voilà
pourquoi la culture hip hop à emprunter
beaucoup à la culture japonaise aux arts
martiaux et à leur philosophie touche
voir sa fille et trois mois je suis
vraiment désolé bruxelles sur fond de
trahison et de vengeance comme toutes
les histoires de samouraï ghost dog
aborde avec humour la confrontation des
cultures dans l'amérique d'aujourd'hui
ouais il se fait appeler ghost dog chais
pas il ya un tas de blagues de nos jours
un tas de gangsters blacks qu'ils ont
des noms comme ça ils s'inventent des
noms comme ça c'est eux
et oui mais il veut dire comme les
rappeurs oui les rappeurs ils ont tous
des noms comme ça snoop tokyo dome ice
cube q-tip method man mon préféré à moi
c'est flava fled de public enemy en
principe nous sommes dans une culture
qui est un mélange de nombreuses
cultures venues d'ailleurs
c'est le côté positif de l'américain
mais c'est comme ça partout il y a
toujours quelque chose à apprendre
quelque chose à apprendre dans la
différence et quand on prend ce quelque
chose c'est comme si toutes les cultures
se mélangent et à l'intérieur de vous
tomber ça c'est contraire au code du
samouraï de te tuer il faut aussi citer
vraiment montréal croit que ça puisse
vouloir dire leur pays et white flag -
ghost dog en vente avec bonheur le
premier flingueurs zèle de l'histoire du
sumo noir pourquoi tu as fais ça tu me
le demandait je vais pas te manquer de
respect